قصه حزينه تتعقد بمرور الوقت ولا حلول
واضحه في الافق شنو ذات طفل عاش لاربع
سنوات مع اسره مسيحيه قررت احتضانه وتبنيه
بعدما وجدته في الكنيسه رضيعا يبلغ يوما
واحدا لكن السلطات قررت نزع الحضانه من
الابوين وايداعه احدى دور الرعايه بعدما
تلقت بلاغا من الطفل مخطوف والقت القبض
على الابوين بتهمه التزوير قبل ان يطلق
سراحهما لثبوت حسن النيه المهم ان الاسره
تحاول اعاده الطفل منذ اكثر من عام
بعد سته اشهر من المداولات لعدم الاختصاص
وطعن الابوان على القرار ولا يزال في
القصه بقيه
بس روح البيت
لغايه دلوقتي عمال يعيط
[موسيقى]
كل شرفاء مصر بلا استثناء الا القله يعني
المتطرفه تدعم هذه السيده الجميله وتدعم
امومتها الامومه هي الرعايه
والعطاء والسهر من اجل
رعايه الصغار وليست الانجاب والتخلي
وبالتالي فكلنا معها انا كنت معاها في
المحكمه يوم 18 مارس لما رفضت الدعوه لعدم
الاختصاص بعد تداول في القضاء لمده سنه
مثلا او اكثر الولد بقى له سنه وشهرين لم
يرى امه ولم ترى هي الا مره واحده ساعه
الطب الشرعي
ومحروم وهو لا يفهم شيء خمس سنين وكان
اربع سنين ساعتها لا يفهم ماذا يجري لهذا
انا كتبت قصيده على لسان شنوده عنوانها
ايها الكبار لن احتفل معكم بعيد الام لانه
لا يفهم ماذا يجري يعني ايه
يتحرم من حضن امه فانا فكرت لان احنا
هنبدا
السيده امال يعني سؤال خلينا نحكي شوي
قانونيا عندما فكرتي بتبني جدوده لماذا لم
تدرسي القوانين او تلجئي لمحامي مختص
بالتبني بتكون يمكن الطريقه اسهل حضرتك
انا ما فكرتش في اي حاجه انا بقالي سنين
وصدقت ما لقيتش نوضه صدقت وما لقيته في
الكنيسه وخدته وحده ضانته ده يوم كان عنده
يوم اربع سنين احتضنت وسبت علينا
لقيته في الكنيسه في حمام الكنيسه فالاب
الكاهن قال لي طالما انت ماسكه فيه
وما معكيش اطفال خديه ولما ريحته
من الشارع يعني عندها هويه او لا الطفل
عندها هويه باسمكم او لا الطفله خدته لمده
باسمنا باسمنا مستحيل مستحيل ام مسلمه
هتحطه في الكنيسه ومستحيل ام مسيحيه هتحطه
في جامع احنا في مصر معروف كده ان الطفل
يعني الطفل الذي يولد على يعني بشكل انا
اسفه يعني
سفاحا المسلمه بتحطه في جامع والمسيحيه
بتحط كنيسه واضح جدا ان الطفل مسيحي ده
اذا تكلمت عن العقيده
[موسيقى]